hey Olivia sure they're there what did
you say
truth or dare
truth or dare
Marky's constantly cheating on Lucas
[Music]
it's true Louis wait lucky I don't know
what's going on I'm serious I'm seeing
things touch me again and I'll break
that hand
it's a game what it is it followed us
home are you being serious
harder it's what we did it was real that
we were all in and that it would find us
we're really taking the word of our
mentally unstable Torgo what else do you
explain what happened to me in the
library huh
and now Ronnie oh I don't know maybe he
was drunk and he fell off a pool table
which is what how incidents that he was
supposed to be doing it there yes Carter
said tell the truth or you die do the
dare or you die Ronnie chickened out he
did not he was there and now he's dead
but he's tell me I'm not crazy
I had to ask you truth or dare
are you aware that olivia is in love
with your boyfriend she's mine we stop
vanellope damn
Miguel Olivia let's get this party
started type garnet truth what are your
intentions with our suite Olivia I
needed to find someone with friends that
I could trick into coming here I could
tell Olivia was an easy target I brought
you all up here cuz I'm okay with
strangers dying if it means I get to
live what the hell game's real okay
wherever you go what have you do it'll
find you okay something really weird has
been going on ever since Mexico oh come
on
I'm seeing things truth all right there
dare I know it sounds insane
just something this fine young lady here
dared me to show you my business Carter
said tell the truth or you die do the
dare or you die refuse the plate you
don't screw this and you die
[Music]
we're not playing the game
it's playing us so what do we do only
choose truth wait I'm sorry touch me
again and I'll break that hand truth
that's not how this works
only game decides honey break Olivia's
hand you have to do it look as pissed as
I am at you right now there's no way I'm
gonna break your hand you don't really
have a choice
God just do it this game is too smart
half the people in this photo are now
dead we need to find what started all
this how do we get out of this game
alive
you can't it's on the ends when all the
players are dead maybe a trans next dare
me to choose look for one of you to kill
truth or dare
you